في الاثناء دعت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع الى التوصل الى اتفاق على
وقف اطلاق نار جديد وتنفيذه بشكل فعال
بهدف بناء وقف دائم للعمليات العسكريه
وقال بيان لوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
الرياض وواشنطن حريصه على استمرار
المحادثات مع وفدي التفاوض السودانيين
وقالت الخارجيه في بيان ان السعوديه
والولايات المتحده على استعداد لاستئناف
المحادثات الرسميه السودانيه مشيره الى ان
وفدي الجيش والدعم السريع لا يزالان
موجودين في جده رغم تعليق المحادثات
وانهاء وقف اطلاق النار واكد بيان الخارجي
السعوديه ان على طرفي الصراع الالتزام
باعلان جده وحمايه المدنيين في السودان